so you see this look what it shows jobs
created by President per month to go to
Joe Biden look at that Trump terrible
Obama Bush Clinton doesn't tell the
whole story that covet happened the last
you know year of trump and then read the
comments zoom in on the comments zoom in
on the comments okay zoom in go up after
him these are not Cherry Picked they're
just okay so trust me bro let's let's
first put it let's first read what the
POTUS said this is what happens when you
invest in America we have more work to
do but this is real progress Source
trust me bro now show me a line graph of
total job still yeah employment rate
before pandemic 61.5 now six and a half
you're not creating anything Society
just covering it up I would love for you
to define the world create award Creator
be be created and restored are two
different things by the way if I tell
you 99 of the comments there's a guy
that says trust me I'm a Democrat and
you're lying yeah he says go look at my
profile on my Instagram I hate Trump I
hate the Santa This Is A Lie right yeah
so
advertisers that one right there bro
this isn't even accurate I'm not a
republican but by the way there's 50 of
these in there that's not just one of
them chart is a bit misleading you're
gonna spend 30 minutes going through all
of it the point the great thing about
what's going on today is the following
here's a great thing uh uh remember that
one song It's Friday Friday
yeah I'm like why am I even listening to
this song that's what's driving me
insane I'm listening it's Friday it's
Friday and and then you're like dude
look at the comments it was like the
worst dislike you know thumbs down uh
video ever on YouTube she broke the
record and they interviewed her you know
165 million views how many is he's not
gonna show the thumbs down that's what I
want to see you can pause it because we
don't want her to say yeah I now get the
rights for this video but but the point
I'm trying to make is the great thing
about what direction we're going God
willing if we go this direction the fact
that Instagram allows for comments till
today and doesn't allow them to
and and they don't even do it yet
because you could do it on Instagram if
they wanted to block it YouTube would
block the comment section ads that they
were manipulating making money in 2010
yeah now you can't do it and get away
with it all of this stuff is getting in
the direction of transparency hopefully
if they can pull this off that's when
you realize who's doing it right and
who's not doing it right yeah but but do
you think it's like because mind you
there there's a huge majority that
believe everything that this guy is
saying whatever this Administration is
saying he's the front runner and all
that all the lying like if you watch the
White House briefings Tim uh Korean
Jean-Pierre she's just blatantly lying
every single day about the board and
everything and not one not one only what
Peter Ducey wants well nobody ever goes
excuse me you're full of nobody's
doing it well she said the other day the
responsible thing the president had to
do it was not fair to have the kids stay
home you know the president make the
right decision to let them back to
school because it was hard on you know
what what are you talking about lady
right with all this stuff no the point
all the stuff I'm talking yeah and he's
talking about Vice and Soros yeah my
biggest concern isn't uh uh some of
these things that's going on my biggest
concern is who's picking up all these
media companies no one on the right one
and picked up Vice who picks it up so
Rose so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]